bonsoir Monsieur Ibrahimi bonsoir merci
d'être avec nous ce soir on a beaucoup
parlé d'aviation au cours des dernières
semaines derniers jours
Ottawa veut intervenir des députés qui
veulent avoir des comptes des compagnies
aériennes concrètement qu'est-ce que ta
voix peut faire dans ce dossier là peut
faire beaucoup de choses et le problème
c'est que ta voix ne fait pas grand
chose depuis
là on voit un petit peu mais regardez
ces dernières années je dirais il a
fallu se battre beaucoup pour que au
Canada on a un charte de passager on est
parmi les derniers pays de l'eg20 à
avoir finalement eu une charte alors que
tous les pays en ont fait en deux
parties une charte qui est bien c'est
beaucoup mieux que rien mais quand même
il y a des trous mais à chaque fois
comme si ce secteur les passagers
n'avaient pas d'importance pour le
gouvernement canadien il a fallu à
chaque fois qu'on arrive jusqu'à les
scandale dans les médias qu'on voit par
exemple des gens dans les files de
passeport qu'on voit par exemple des
gens qui font un avion non un avion pour
aller vers le sud alors dans des
absolument inacceptable des aéroports
comme si ce secteur qui est pourtant
extrêmement important dans notre
économie science secteur structurant à
chaque fois qu'on met un dollars
là-dedans il s'habille en a deux ou
trois fois qu'il revient dans l'économie
comme si on avait abandonné et alors
comme ça on l'a abandonné les compagnies
aériennes comme tous les acteurs font
n'importe quoi dans la mesure où les
sanctions sont pas là quand on regarde
par exemple aux États-Unis à cause de la
tempête plusieurs milliers devant l'été
annulés très bien mais regardez dans les
jours qui ont celui pratiquement 48
heures 72 heures après le secrétaire
donc transport est intervenu des a
convoqué ça fait 10 jours nous regardez
ça près presque deux semaines plus deux
semaines on voit une situation
absolument chaotique là finalement le
ministre du bas je vais faire une
commission on va voir est-ce que
nous avons parce que le système me
défend pourtant il y a des organ
ismes que la charte soit respectée on a
l'office de transport qui doit faire ça
mais c'est justement là c'est à dire
regarder dans les dernières dans les
depuis qu'on a charte combien de
sanctions on a imposé accompagné
aérienne est-ce que ces sanctions-là
étaient assez importantes pour que ça
soit disside quand on regarde tout ça on
voit que le bilan n'est pas
nécessairement très positif donc les
passagers sont un petit peu sont un peu
abandonnés donc ce contrat qui est
essentiel entre une compagnie aérienne
et un passager au moment où la lâche le
billet est acheté comme si c'est pris à
la légère et donc le bien-être le le la
qualité de vie ce qu'on appelle perte
jouissance donc de passagers qui doit
partir comme si ça ça intéresse personne
donc on abandonne un petit peu les
passagers les citoyens et ça vraiment il
est temps que ça change dans ce pays
concrètement les gens qui ont été
coincés dans un aéroport dans le temps
des fêtes qu'est-ce qu'il peut faire
alors écoutez quand un biais est acheté
que ça soit même de ce condition sous
contrôle ou hors de contrôle d'une
compagnie aérienne la première chose
c'est que ils ont le droit c'est à dire
que la compagnie même c'est pour une
raison de météo pour une brume mécanique
non prévisible donc la compagnie à
l'obligation de leur proposer des
alternatives il faut les mettre soit du
vol plus tard dans la journée ou en tout
cas quand la situation le permet soit
sur les ailes de notre compagnie ou
alors de les rembourser dans 48 heures
donc les gens peuvent revendiquer que ça
si vraiment il y a des indemnisations
prévues exactement et puis si on peut
prouver que c'est sur le contrôle de la
compagnie en plus de ces éléments là
c'est le remboursement ça il y a des
dédommagements en termes de nombre
d'heures de retard en terme de page
annulation de vote ils ont justement des
chartes prévoient ça pour pas que les
compagnies annulent les vols pour des
raisons économiques et autres donc et
mais ça c'est vraiment les gens doivent
insister à mon avis il faut en plus moi
je leur conseille c'est l'accompagner
aérienne vous dit non ne n’arrêtez pas
la relancer relancer et puis voilà
d'aller de l'avant parce que
ça donne des résultats quand même mais
il faut pas abandonner des compagnies
aériennes mises sur le fait que les gens
sont découragés à la première réponse
négatif mais il faut pas le faire il
faut aller plus loin les compagnies
aériennes parlent souvent de la pénurie
de main d'oeuvre comme une cause de leur
problème mais est-ce qu'elles en ont
fait assez pour pallier cette pénurie de
mes deux voilà ça c'est tout à fait vrai
c'est je sais que en ce moment on entend
beaucoup mais c'est vrai que les
compagnies aériennes ont des problèmes
de main d'oeuvre ça c'est vrai mais ils
ont mis à pied
quand on disait il faut supporter le
secteur pour pas que des gens que les
compagnies se mettent les gens donc à
pied justement on voit aujourd'hui le
résultat cependant il y a des compagnies
qui surexploitent leur personnel et
maintenant de la marge de manœuvre comme
sandwich et ça donne des résultats
catastrophes du catastrophiques que les
autres merci beaucoup d'avoir été avec
nous bonne soirée pour voir nos
émissions en entier rendez-vous sur la
chaîne ici RDI
[Musique]